now I want to see the level disrespect
but I believe that HR people need to
believe themselves more and have a
bigger impact look at this guy what
right there that's the Eiffel Tower
not even a branch not the best place to
travel to when you are on a calorie
restriction
what's that belief nation happy weekend
I am on my way that Paris and I'm taking
you guys with me not what I'm making a
loving mother not whether you hate it
but you guys get the coat
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm going to be eating at an event in
Paris for a company called talent soft
in talking about the role of digital and
leadership or the human resource
industry which is great it came as a
result of some of that I worked with at
Sage who left stage and went off to go
to kalabaw and this happens a lot in
either be businesses if you're selling
the business you want to make sure you
have a great relationship with everybody
involved because it's so often that
people will jump from one company to
another if you have a great relationship
they're going to bring me with garlic
has to go I haven't been to Paris first
twenty five or six years lots of mileage
with Nina and so I'm at Airport a little
bit early in the check-in Mikus and
allergies so hopefully those go away I'm
ready to have a great time one of the
benefits about flying business time to
do for my corporate stuff you get to go
to an airport lounge in
I got to find mine relaxing deliver work
they had a minute you would not fire so
if you notice from my food
he pretty light I'm a special new diet
that my personal care to cook me on who
I have a track how would we go to daily
basis a lot of something that I had no
idea when it was so I'm going to go find
myself it yet
Booster Juice downstairs France not the
best place to travel to when you are on
account instructions we'll see how it
goes and they'll try to guess assess it
[Music]
alright got my bananas away
three to come
370 calories busy like 600 couple left
with a fight fingers cry I got a little
bit back in time before chicken so I'm
going to do some social media love paint
some people's questions on my phone I'm
on Twitter Instagram snapchat at airport
applying great way to kill time value
I would forgotten champion boxer
checking in visit pot so I get the
middle teacher I got good news the guys
next to me are traveling together
but I have the fit the middle anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right landed in Paris these chairs
are cool check this out
those lie-down chairs in the plane were
awesome couldn't sleep though mix of
congestion and the guy coughing not
optivisor coffered seven hours straight
must be bras anyway happened to be here
in Paris going to go find my uber driver
I guess for the some driver think we
have hit the villa Cal and try to get a
little bit of sleep it is 7:00 in the
morning
Terrace time means I'm looking forward
to your mind at the exit I guess that's
communism's knocking time like I needed
it be so I'm standing in that crazy line
which is me a chance to answer some
messages on social media all right are
we got up that's at least an hour
oh it's crazy I just got a message that
my divers here waiting for me worried
that I'm not showing up so gotta go find
him very excited it doesn't look down
Julie
[Music]
alright I'm all checked in
number six oh eight three ready think
we'll check out my room so people like
counting here who set me up here my
client my friend asked me how my flight
was so on the one hand the flight wasn't
that great you know no Wi-Fi the TV
system went down and lost my spot in the
movies
I couldn't sleep because of my allergies
I couldn't sleep because this guy was
coughing ahead of me the whole night and
so you know not the best experience but
on the other hand food was great I got
to sit on the aisle because that guy
wanted to sit with his friend you know I
got those awesome seats that reclined
I know for all is a great experience and
so was it a good flight was it a bad
flight well it was both it really just
depends on what side of the coin you
look at and I think that applies to most
other things that our lives it's 10:30
I got here at 7:00 it's been three and a
half hours through security and
everything else to get here and I'm
grateful I'm happy I'm ready to sleep
but I'm happy to be in a hotel I have a
place to go and so with every situation
there's always something to find this
negative and there's also that if you
find a positive is it a good flight or a
bad flight is that thing you're creating
right now good or bad - just depends on
your outlook trying to look on the
positive side that can may help the come
here 608 - look at these doors ha ha all
right look at this bathroom with that's
pretty funky to have enough shower got a
nice bathroom look at that guy what
let's go it I got two little beds that's
cool you're squishing together get my TV
get some CNN on well because those lamps
it's pretty cool oh these are those
showers that are
a little bit see-through you can't
actually see through but to like it
through look at this view party just
with just with your sweet hood it's just
really Rea just really great JD very
jazzy vain old man my French my French
has to come back
first we're going to set up have a quick
nap so much time I have left afterwards
in the practice my speech goes to Xavier
if I have a little bit of time go check
out some of the scenes around here take
you guys with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so got about five hours nap
there
one is the Duomo I had to get up because
if I had a huge sleep that I wouldn't
sleep tonight and tomorrow as an
important presentation day so I've got a
couple hours before me to half year and
going to dinner which is it you think is
like 10 o'clock and one in three so I'm
going to head out into town practice
what I'm going to be thinking about for
my speech taking some of the sights and
that's exactly so figuring out the
French stuff with specifics is fun with
a couple of our turn but I think I
finally know where I'm going and I'm
heading to the shelves that we say the
most famous streets in France in your
checked out the yeah health the cleome
the Arch of Triumph
No
[Music]
[Applause]
so just behind me hope the site right
there that's the Eiffel Tower the scene
will see the back there McGee Vesnina
last time we came here it was uh it was
a big surprise we got off to Paris fans
know nice and we're on the way to the
airport right now
no way I just showed up at her work I
booked the next day off of her work and
we went from the weekend it came it was
me in the first time to Paris in the
mist in here right now hope she's doing
okay I got to bring her back down sign I
got to bring her back you know I got to
bring you back here got to bring you
back to you
[Music]
so they've really beefed up security I
can't even get in
around the power kind of go up to the
various levels of the FT powerful
getting close to it without going to
security of the same for all the same
general out the pregame whistle aside
both side that kind of come to that
booklet temporary thing but I'm not
going to go in it offline the same in
line you got to get back instead of a
shower and then meet up with heavier I
remember when I came here with Nina I'm
still objective out there it is there
are these flowers and you know I'm to
stop and look at them and just
appreciate them and it doesn't mean I
love doing she loves appreciating nature
appreciating the flowers one of these
bushes I think if this was actually you
know when I travel for business I don't
really do a lot of the touristy things I
don't really need to I'm not like will
my god it's checked our but I've been
here a number of times already tooth is
probably it I'm a mix so far when I'm
doing this stuff of one just focusing on
my talk what I'm going to say you know
I'm missing four days for this so I
better deliver some serious value
tomorrow of my speech I wasted my time
here that was with that collection
myself so got one side there but the
other side I'm just missing Nina a lot I
mean I knew I'd miss there but I missing
her a lot more than I expected I guess
to get to the history that we have here
to be in power property or the content
we've had still on a travel without Nina
and missus we're a lot anyway to helping
the subway I head back to the hotel and
have a quick shower and up with Xavier
and go for dinner McDonald's over there
one of the things that I always used to
do I wouldn't really care about food in
city until Nina I still don't really
care that much just every time I travel
I now I need to book food and because
Nina loves trying to local I would much
rather just go and just kill the city as
much stuff as possible and stopping in
the restaurants seem to be like a waste
of time I'm still not a huge fan but how
we do it for Nina
but anyway McDonald's used to always be
my home when I traveled because in out
try something kind of kind of local all
those fears to see what they had that
was different
McDonald's and Starbucks so they had a
blue cheese bacon burger hey poochie's
but even just thinking but I always used
to do go to McDonald's we check out
what's really different and try that
I made it back I've got two minutes ago
and I'm excited all right had a great
shower relaxed a little bit thought
about what I was going to say tomorrow
if I my speech change my shirt
toast different shirt look at that
amazing shirt and now I'm going to meet
Javier in the lobby there is mr. Javier
how you doing mr. moon how you doing
I'm here on the shell did eat a but the
found there's a pound soft there's one
got more in the back behind we're going
to go have some dinner that's some good
talk excited not want to see the level
disrespect but I believe that HR people
need to believe themselves more and have
a bigger impact I'm frustrated that for
CEOs don't come from HR positions
especially in North America Aziz so to
come from HR and I believe that we
should just be complaining about it we
should be the leaders and Commissioner
Jeep and some are going over some new
ideas that I have that may help you guys
and York on my mind it's an honor to be
here and have some great discussions and
I see a lot of talent a lot of
leadership in this room and I hope that
you'll take the information that you
learn tomorrow back home to your
companies
to make a mark on your industry as you
ever recruit great dinner some really
awesome conversations actually some
people in shape putting people to do
bigger bolder things you know usual
believe kind of stuff
it's I have no time at this I want to
say eleven o'clock Paris time who I also
got to macaron put it in communication I
greens
I probably destroyed my my calorie
intake for the day on your head back to
the hotel probably practice my speech
one more time but through based on the
new information I kind of got today I
love really tailoring the content I'm
putting that depending on the people
I've been on the audience so it's always
great to be able to connect with the
eyes a little bit in advance to just she
lit up here what the challenges are and
you can create something much better
than just a standard thing that might
deliver in an event so that was good I'm
going to read you get a little bit
practice see if I can get ahold of Nina
what she's up to
it's been wake up tomorrow morning and
let's go question